So we have to start today digging further into
the supposed covid relief bill, a so-called
rescue package for I guess it's supposed to be
for Americans, even though it's really apparently
for corporations and rich people. And this has
now been approved by Congress. And this may be
one of the biggest scams of 2020. And there
have been many scams in twenty twenty. The
Trump campaign was a scam. Trump's handling of
of covid was a massive scam and failure. Trump's
continued claims of things like it's the flu,
15 cases will go to zero. That's a massive scam.
Trump's campaign fundraising to launder money
through a shell company to his family. It's a
scam. Trump fundraising after the election,
claiming the money will help him overturn
the results when it's really going 50 percent to
help him pay off his campaign. It's a scam after
scam. This is the year of scams. But this
covid rescue package is a major scam. Now,
as I told you yesterday, it's a 900 billion dollar
total package. It's part of a bigger package that
includes one point four dollars trillion for
funding government. So you wrap a bunch of
stuff not related to covid into the relief bill
and then connect it to the spending bill. It's
not super clear why, but that's not necessarily a
problem. But then you see the details for people,
not corporations, just normal people making
up to seventy five thousand dollars a year.
They get 600 dollars per adult. You get an extra
three hundred dollars per week of unemployment
if you are out of a job altogether. And on state
unemployment for 11 months, money might start
going out as soon as next week, maybe last time it
took months and months. So we'll see. But the real
story here is the pathetic nature of how money
for people compares to money for everything else,
including corporations after remember, seven
months of nothing being done. So let's go through
it. I mentioned that combining the one point four
trillion dollar bill to fund government with the
900 billion covid relief is not necessarily a
problem. And it's not necessarily a problem,
except here it is a problem because in total, the
two things together are more than 1500 pages. And
the vote took place last night, just a few hours
after the full text was released, again, ensuring
that no member of Congress could actually see what
they were voting for. This is a common scam in our
government. It happens all the time. And one
of the things that was stuck into the bill is
that it would make it illegal. It would make it a
felony to illegally stream video as an example, as
well as a bunch of other pro corporate handouts in
terms of intellectual property. And Congresswoman
Alexandrea Cassio, court has pointed this out and
explained this is an example of what they didn't
have time to read, tweeting, quote, This is why
Congress needs time to actually read this package
before voting on it. Members of Congress have not
read this bill. It's over five thousand pages,
arrived at 2:00 p.m. today and we are told to
expect a vote in two hours. This isn't governance.
It's hostage taking. And she's correct. The bill
has a handout of one hundred and twenty billion
to rich business owners and other provisions that
are great for the wealthy. There's a provision
that businesses that get loans can not only have
the loans forgiven, meaning it's free money,
but they can also deduct the loan amount spent on
business expenses against their taxable income. So
you get a million dollar loan as an example, you
don't have to pay it back. So it's really a gift
of a million dollars. But then also the stuff you
spend the money on from the loan, which was free,
you deduct from your taxes and it lowers your
taxable income. I mean, it's truly wild. And
meanwhile, some people will get 600 dollars. Now,
I there's this other provision about increasing
the deductibility of meals from 50 percent to 100
percent. Some people are mad about this as well.
I've dealt with this before. Like if I go to a
conference for a week and I spend a few hundred
dollars on meals during the conference or I take
the team out for dinner, if you can imagine that.
I mean, you know, it's covid. But at the time when
we did if I spend 100 bucks on meals for the team,
I can only deduct 50 of it. Only 50 of it
essentially is a tax deductible expense.
They want to up that to 100. They have up that
to 100 percent. I like it. And then it benefits
me. This is the only thing that I get. And this is
an opportunity for me to to mention again, people
keep emailing me saying, David, you greedy
bastard, you want more money for yourself,
you want twelve hundred dollars instead of six
hundred. Again, I'm getting nothing. I qualify for
nothing. I would benefit from the hundred percent
deductibility of meals as a business expense if
there's ever a thing as a business meal again.
OK, but I'm we've taken no money. I get no money.
Personally, I have no kids that they get money, I
get nothing. OK, I'm thinking about other people.
So this is way bigger than any one thing is
the point. And part of this is that lots of
Democrats are fine with all this stuff, just like
Republicans. Some are not like AOC, but she still
voted for it because six hundred dollars is better
than nothing. And she was given two hours to read
5500 pages. Part of this is that there simply
isn't even time to know what's in the bill,
as I mentioned. And then part of this is
that at a systemic level, how do you go seven
months with nothing and then offer six hundred
dollars while giving huge corporations tons of
goodies and handouts? It's quite frankly,
infuriating. This is what we have now.
Let's see what happens after January 20th with a
different president and we don't yet know, maybe
a different party controlling the Senate. And
again, those Georgia races are very much in focus.